can you give us examples of a show that
you built off a great character and then
one where you started off a great
premise I'll tell you my favorite uh
from us from a character there was a
show that Bravo ran for many years
called flipping out
I loved that show and I was there from
the ground uh one of the first things I
did on the show was I went out and we
had lunch with Jeff Lewis who was the
star of that show
who is a really interesting guy who has
actual OCD
and that was kind of the thing was the
show was about him and the people that
worked for him and how they deal with
him having this very particular manner
of doing things that is actually a
medically diagnosed thing
and about how he tries to bring himself
in but sometimes can't
and I thought he was just such an
interesting guy that when we did the
pilot for the show there were so many
times we would turn in a cut of the show
and the note would come back like the
show is called flipping out he's not
flipping out enough and I was like he's
such a real guy like how do we
how do we satisfy the network but we
also you know treat him like a person
and there was one scene and I almost
never fight
anybody about content they were like
they were kind of like underwhelmed by
it there was a scene at the end of the
first episode where he goes to see his
therapist
and the therapist folds this Navajo
blanket up into a big square and puts it
over his face and says I want you to
scream as loud as you can and he says I
can't under the blanket and I was just
like my heart broke I was like I feel so
bad for him that this is a real thing
that he has to deal with every day that
he knows
drives people to work with him nuts
but him just I can't like I thought that
was like the most beautiful scene I ever
had the opportunity to cut it was
nothing nothing that I asked for it was
something that came back from the field
as part of them following him as part of
his day
and it just still to watch that first
episode I get choked up when I see that
because I'm like this is a this is a
real person having a real life
experience who is not being reduced to a
cartoon character of himself for the
convenience of the storytellers
and that show went on progressively you
know
I got the Feeling watching it in later
Seasons that there was a lot of playing
things up for the camera it might have
been it might not have been it might
have been just as genuine as it was when
I started on that show well we set that
tone right and you really felt like you
knew him as a person
you have empathy for him
you start out sometimes where they you
know the idea for the show is oh here's
this guy who's constantly flipping out
and there's this push
that you know you've got to have your
Heroes and your villains so everybody
gets crammed into this mold like don't
forget this person's the villain don't
forget this is the good person who just
has to suffer through the villain and if
you watch enough seasons of certain
shows where it's just like oh well you
know Carol's just like that and this one
character is just tearing into people
unmotivated constantly
I always think like does she think that
she's not going to end up in the show if
she's not bombastic enough because she
thinks that's what reality shows are
and that's the problem with reality TV
being everywhere now that it's just like
they want these crazy nasty characters
but you can't understand why they are
who they are like there's a bunch of
backstory that you're not getting into
conversely I think they're characters
who are entirely reliant on having had a
backstory it's very difficult doing a
premise-based pilot for any show script
or unscripted
um I don't need to know where this
person went to fifth grade I don't need
to know that they sneezed once with a
mouth full of taco and embarrassed
themselves in front of the classroom
but there are some people are like yeah
we want to know the whole the whole deal
like what's what's with this person how
did they meet their husband how did they
do this and I'm like I don't care what's
happening right now like I can figure
out who a person is in the moment
more easily than I can if you stop me
down and go I'm going to tell you
everything that's happened in this
person's life up until now I
so slow total snails pace
like you know they used to live here but
then they moved here and then they moved
to this other place and that's where
they met this person who's in the show
doesn't matter if they're arguing over a
topping on a pizza and they're married
no I can meet them in the middle of that
argument and figure out who they are
watching that argument happen
that's super organic backstory is very
inorganic
you're slowing the proceedings down by
telling me everything about them before
I start
how do you know when you have a great
idea
for me it's it's just when it tickles me
when I laugh when I
am in the middle of watching something
down and the people start to feel like
people
there's a point where reality television
the most important thing in what I do
has always been it has to feel authentic
and you you CA the irony of saying this
out loud you can fake authenticity to a
degree
but when it's when it's the real deal
and you're really invested in someone's
success
that to me is like when I'm having fun
and when I'm having fun I know the
product is going to be good because I
feel like it'll catch on and whoever has
to review that and sign off and give
notes hopefully we'll experience the
same thing that I'm feeling organically
watching it
what elements make a great idea
um
the fact that when it's when it's
salable and it fits in a box even if
it's even if it's its own box
when people come to me and they're like
I have an idea that nobody's ever done
before my initial reaction is
like I know what this is going to taste
like
like What's It Gonna What's it gonna be
like when you know somebody else sees it
and goes well this doesn't fit our
schedule or this isn't this isn't the
flavor of programming that we're looking
for right now
um it's not it's not always completely
about originality it's about
knowing that it fits somewhere and
knowing that it'll resonate I I
especially like things that are projects
that I feel will resonate with fans of
other shows that I like
like if you did if I did a show right
now that felt like
the office I'd be thrilled
I I often compare even unscripted shows
like I'm trying to figure out what the
what the brothers and sisters of that
show are like like unsung
not unsung I'm sorry
what was Unreal was the show that they
did about reality television
and I could watch more than two episodes
in a row because I'd get sick to my
stomach that it was like
picking apart the kind of thing that I
do for a living but it was super
engaging and they had the the producer
that had kind of an over to the top
personality who was very interesting but
was definitely like an alpha type guy
you had Executives that were on this
fictional show that I would say oh that
reminds me of so-and-so oh no like
that's like is this a straight parody of
the show like it's it's too close
and I was in you know I got invested in
that and I felt like this is a show that
really Nails the feeling of how I felt
working on this other thing and if
people love this thing they're going to
love this other show
if I do if I do anything that feels like
something else like that the clothing
show I was talking about earlier if it
felt like as much fun as making it if it
ever got made
I would not be surprised because the
whole time I was writing up the deck to
pitch that show I was just laughing out
loud
I had people attached to that it was my
my hosts if I pitched it I always
pitched with a host attached even if the
production company says no we don't like
that guy and for me like I I had pitched
it and I had Daniel Francis who was who
played Damien and Mean Girls
attached as a host and Erica De La Cruz
who is the publisher of La Girl magazine
who was quite the Fashionista
um I took her to the Emmys one year and
she ended up in
some I think it was the Paris Vogue
she had worn a yellow dress and they
just she walked the carpet
talked about the designer and it's just
like
she at that time was not a huge
celebrity but she's so personable and so
energetic and she's now got a social
media following to beat the band like he
wouldn't believe how well she does on
tick tock
and I thought well you know if these two
said yes and they would do it I can go
in and not only have a great idea but
have it fairly well fleshed out so that
if somebody said yes I'd like make these
two calls tomorrow and you've got your
hosts and then just let's get moving
if it feels good enough that you can
visualize it happening as opposed to
just feeling the sort of therapeutic
wish of like oh I got something out of
me
that's what you hoped for
this is along the same lines but what
can you do to test your idea
um I used to say talk to talk to your
friends in the industry
uh I don't necessarily recommend that
anymore
I've had a couple of couple of shows
that I've presented that felt eerily
similar to things that my friends have
created
and I know it's incidental and that
ideas are everywhere and execution is a
hundred percent of the deal
but it still sort of feels like I don't
want to be too verbal about this because
you can talk an idea away you can lose
your passion for something by repeating
it to too many people so when you create
something be excited that you finished
your screenplay be excited that you
finished your pilot
don't feel like you have to show it to
everybody you know and get that instant
Rush of oh they liked it too
because that doesn't help I mean they're
not paying to read it you're not going
to make a living off of writing
something and showing it to your friends
write it
if you're working with a consultant show
it to a consultant who has done it
before and knows what they're doing and
listen to their feedback your friends
don't know
what works and what doesn't and what's
of the moment
unless they're people who are working in
that industry
I appreciate you saying the part about
you know be cautious of who you show it
to because I think there's like these
two camps there's those that think that
oh Nobody Does this and then there's
others that and then I think that
they're somewhere in the middle and and
look Steve Jobs was paranoid for a
reason you know they say that he didn't
want people to know certain things and
and but you also can't you also can't
work in this business if you're
Paralyzed by the fear of someone
stealing something that you've created
and ultimately if you've created
something really good it should click so
easily with people
that anybody in their right mind would
go oh that is a great idea
but if they think oh that is a great
idea and two years later they come up
with something that's almost the same
thing because it's just in the back of
their mind somewhere
the few shows I've had where I've
pitched a show and then I see it on TV
later
I've never said that person stole my
idea I say oh maybe that was running
around on the back of their head
so it must have been good and ultimately
you just have to figure out a way to
filter it and say well it is a good idea
and it lived so I feel
validated that it happened whether I
made a penny from it or not
do you like to start with great
characters
or a great premise
uh always I always start from premise
and characters are almost easy because
what I do when I when I write
particularly the the fictional the
fiction efforts I've tried
is when I write I can basically
cannibalize
the entirety of uh human existence that
I have filed in the back of my head do
you remember your first grade teacher
that had that weird voice that always
used to do this and had this quirky
thing and only talked about this
that is a character that you can shove
into a great idea
and then it becomes easier for you to
write because you're basically
pretending that these people are talking
to each other
and then the dialogue feels natural the
characters feel more fleshed out
that's the thing like that the I wrote a
book called 100 poems about Los Angeles
every single poem in that book
is based on a real interaction I've had
I had a homeless man practically assault
me
in a sushi restaurant
when I was in Hollywood that came in and
he walked up to the counter he goes I'm
going to have this and that and the
other and that guy's going to pay for it
and he looked at me like he was waiting
for me to fight him
and I said whatever
and the guy like
was kind of put off and he's like I bet
you feel really good about yourself
like I guess I do what's it to you and
he was almost upset that I was enjoying
you know the interaction
and that's one of my favorite pieces in
the book
it's based on a real guy just like if I
read a fictional thing he's actually
he's actually
uh a character in The Pilot that I'm
writing that's based on that book
and what happened did he take his food
and go
no he ended up coming over he sat down
with me because I would not give him an
inch
and I said you want to see that yeah he
is I have a name and I said what's your
name I'm Troy
I'm not going to tell you this whole
thing I just hope this whole weird
Kabuki that he had going on in his head
about he was going to show this guy by
making some stranger pay for his dinner
and it's like I didn't care
I'd rather you be eating that than
walking down the street and spend you
know three dollars on something that's
not nutritious and not good for you
you know a nice Sushi meal is
always something that makes me feel good
so enjoy it make yourself feel good